I have a two-year-old daughter named
Naya who's under the mistaken impression
that this conference is named in honor
of her father Who am I to contradict my
baby girl as many of you know there's
something about becoming a parent that
concentrates the mind on long-term
problems like climate change it was the
birth of my daughter that inspired me to
launch this climate organization in
order to counteract the excessive
polarization of this issue in the United
States and to find a conservative
pathway forward yes folks a Republican
climate solution is possible and you
know what it may even be better let me
try to prove that to you what we really
need is a killer app to climate policy
in the technology world a killer app is
an application so transformative that it
creates its own market like uber in the
climate world a killer app is a new
solution so promising that it can break
through the seemingly insurmountable
barriers to progress these include the
psychological barrier climate advocates
have long been encouraging their fellow
citizens to make short-term sacrifices
now for benefits that accrue to other
people in other countries 30 or 40 years
in the future it just doesn't fly
because it runs contrary to basic human
nature next is the geopolitical barrier
under the current rules of global trade
countries have a strong incentive to
free ride off the emissions reductions
of other nations instead of
strengthening their own programs this
has been the curse of every
international climate negotiations
including Paris finally we have the
partisan barrier even the most committed
countries Germany the United Kingdom
Canada are nowhere near reducing
emissions at the required scale and
speed
not even close and the partisan climate
divide is far more acute here in the
United States we are fundamentally stuck
and that is why we need a killer app of
climate policy to break through each of
these barriers I'm convinced that the
road to climate progress in the United
States runs through the Republican Party
and the business community so in
launching the climate Leadership Council
I started by reaching out to who's who
of Republican elder statesmen and
business leaders including James Baker
and George Schultz the two most
respected Republican elder statesmen in
America Martin Feldstein and Greg Mankiw
the two most respected conservative
economists in the country and Henry
Paulson and Rob Walton - the most
successful and admired business leaders
together we co-authored the conservative
case for carbon dividends this
represents the first time that
Republican leaders put forth a concrete
market-based climate solution thank you
we presented our plan at the White House
two weeks after President Trump moved in
almost every leading editorial board in
the country has since endorsed our plan
and fortune 100 companies from a wide
range of industries are now getting
behind it so by now you're probably
wondering what exactly is this plan well
our carbon dividend solution is based on
four pillars the first is a gradually
rising carbon tax although capitalism is
a wonderful system like many operating
systems it's prone to bugs which in this
case are called market failures by far
the largest is that market prices fail
to take social and environmental costs
into account that means that every
market transaction is based on incorrect
information
and this fundamental bug of capitalism
more than any other single factor is to
blame for a climate predicament now in
theory this should be an easy problem to
fix economists agree that the best
solution is to put a price on the carbon
content of fossil fuels otherwise known
as a carbon tax
this would discourage carbon emissions
in every single economic transaction
every day of the year however a carbon
tax by itself has proven to be unpopular
and a political dead-end the answer is
to return all the money raised directly
to citizens in the form of equal monthly
dividends this would transform an
unpopular carbon tax into a popular and
populist solution and it would also
solve the underlying psychological
barrier that we discussed by giving
everyone a concrete benefit in the here
and now and these benefits would be
significant assuming a carbon tax rate
that starts at $40 per tonne a family of
four would receive $2,000 per year from
the get-go according to the US Treasury
Department the bottom 70 percent of
Americans would receive more in
dividends than they would pay in
increased energy prices that means that
223 million Americans would win
economically from solving climate change
and that is revolutionary and could
fundamentally alter climate politics but
there is another revolutionary element
here the amount of the dividend would
grow as the carbon tax rate increases
the more we protect our climate the more
our citizens benefit this creates a
positive feedback loop which is crucial
because the only way we will reach our
long-term emission reduction goals is if
the carbon tax rate goes up every year
the third pillar of our program is
eliminating regulations that are no
longer needed
once that a carbon dividends plan is
enacted this is a key selling point to
Republicans and business leaders so why
should we trade climate regulations for
a price on carbon well let me show you
our plan would achieve nearly twice the
emissions reductions of all Obama era
climate regulations combined and nearly
three times the new baseline after
President Trump repeals all of those
regulations that assumes a carbon tax
starting at $40 per ton which translates
into roughly an extra 36 cents per that
per gallon of gas our plan by itself
would meet the high end of America's
commitment under the Paris climate
agreement and as you can see the
emissions reductions would continue over
time this illustrates the power of a
conservative climate solution based on
free market and limited government we
would end up with less regulation and
far less pollution at the same time
while helping working-class Americans
get ahead doesn't that sound like
something we could all support
the fourth and final pillar of our
program is a new climate domino effect
based on border carbon adjustment now
that may sound complicated but it too is
revolutionary because it provides us a
whole new strategy to reach a global
price on carbon which is ultimately what
we need let me show you an example
suppose that country a adopts a carbon
dividend plan and country B does not
well to level the playing field and
protect the competitiveness of its
industries country a would tax imports
from country B based on their carbon
content fair enough but here's where it
gets really interesting
because the money raised at the border
would increase the dividends going to
the citizens of country a well how long
do you think it would take the public
and country B to realize that that money
should be going to them and to push for
a carbon defense plan in their own land
add a few more countries and we get a
new climate domino effect once at one
major country or region adopts carbon
dividends with border or carbon
adjustments other countries are
compelled to follow suit one by one the
dominoes fall and this domino effect
could start anywhere
my preference strongly is the United
States but it could also start in the
United Kingdom in Germany or another
European country or even in China
let's take China is an example China is
committed to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions but what its leaders care even
more about is transitioning their
economy to consumer lead economic
development well nothing could do more
to hasten that transition than giving
every Chinese citizen a monthly dividend
in fact this is the only policy solution
that would enable China to meet its
environmental and economic goals at the
same time that's why this is the killer
app of climate policy because it would
enable us to overcome each of the
barriers we discussed earlier the
psychological barrier the partisan
barrier and as we've just seen the
geopolitical barrier
all we need is a country to lead the way
and one method of finding what you're
looking for is to take out an ad so
let's read this one together wanted
countries to pioneer carbon dividends
plan cost the country 0 starting date as
soon as possible advantages most
effective climate solution popular and
populates pro-growth and pro-business
shrinks government and helps the working
class additional compensation gratitude
of current and future generations
including my daughter thank you
it's a traffic on custom desert and I'm
actually not sure I've seen the
conservative get a standing O it said
before that it's pretty cool um so I
mean the logic seems really powerful but
some people you talk to in politics say
you know it's a it's hard to imagine
they're still getting through Congress
how are you feeling about momentum
behind this so I understand that many
are very pessimistic about what's
happening in the United States with
President Trump I'm less pessimistic
here's why the actions of this White
House the early actions on climate are
just the first move in a complex game of
climate chess so far it's been a repeal
only strategy the pressure is going to
mount for a replacement program which is
where we come in and there are three
reasons why which I'll go through real
quickly one the business community is
fundamentally parting ways with the
White House on climate change in fact
we're finding a number of fortune 100
companies supporting our program within
two months we're going to be announcing
some really surprising names coming out
in favor of this program too there is no
issue in American politics where there's
a more fundamental gap between the
Republican base in the Republican
leadership than climate change and three
thinking of this analogy of chess the
big decision up ahead is does the
administration stay in Paris well let's
pan it up both ways if it stays in
Paris's many are pushing for in the
administration well then that begs the
question what's the plan we have the
plan but if they don't stay in Paris the
international pressure will be
overwhelming our Secretary of State will
be asking other countries for native
contributions and I'll be saying no give
us our various commitment come through
on your commitment to welcome to and
ours so international business and even
the Republican base will all be calling
for a Republican replacement plan and
hopefully we've provided one thank you
so much Ted thank you Chris
[Applause]